welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and I'm very excited to
talk about DC's new movie The Flash
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down what happens in it the
comic book influences all those cameos
and what the ending means for the future
please hit the Thumbs Up Button if you
enjoy the video and also don't forget to
subscribe for more breakdowns on the
flash throughout the next couple of
weeks now the movie itself is Loosely
based on the book Flashpoint by Jeff
Johns and Andy cubit in order to
understand what was going on in comics
at the time we first have to time travel
ourselves all the way back to crisis on
infinite Earths which was released in
1985. this mega event came at a time
when Comics it kinda spiraled out of
control and all the multiversal
iterations were getting a bit too much
to keep one contained continuity thus
they had this big crisis event that
allowed them to kill off some of the
characters celebrate others and also
streamline the Canon into one
straightforward thing now one of the
major events that happened in crisis was
the death of Barry Allen who ran so fast
studies seemingly disappeared into
nothing Wally West then took over the
mantle and he became the skull at
Speedster for about the next 20 years
long time it seemed like Barry Allen was
dead but Grant Morrison ended up
bringing him back in final crisis which
allowed Jeff Johns to use the character
on his own run starting off with flash
rebirth This Was Then followed by the
book Flashpoint which this movie is
Loosely based on in that barrier work
one day to find that his mother was
still alive and that the world around
him was vastly different his wife was
with another man he no longer had his
powers and both Atlantis and the mascara
were at war with one another the Justice
League was no more and someone else was
in Batman's caping Cal now in this
iteration it turned out that this was
actually Thomas Wayne with Bruce being
the one that was shot in Crime Alley
Martha actually had a mental breakdown
because of this and in the flashpoint
world she went on to become the joker
now things here are slightly altered
with Bruce still being Batman but
instead he's played by none other than
Michael Keaton arguably the biggest
selling point of the movie I have to
admit that when this was announced I got
nuts and started a break dance with the
devil in the pale Moonlight we'll talk
about it more as we get into the video
but in the flashpoint reality the war
between Aquaman and Wonder Woman was
slowly causing the world to destabilize
and thus Barry went to Wayne Manor in
order to try and work things out
confronted by Thomas he eventually
convinced him he was telling the truth
and the Pair worked together to recreate
the experiment that gave Barry his
powers and when the comics Barry also
managed to release the suit from his
flash ring but this was revealed to be a
yellow one much to the surprise of Barry
surmising that the reverse flash was
behind this all he believed that Donna
changed the timeline to make this world
which was descending into chaos now the
reverse flash doesn't appear in the
movie but one thing that they mirror is
that the group try and track down
Superman in the comic cyborg helped the
pair to discover that he didn't land in
Kansas and instead he was taken in by
the government and kept underground
basked in red sunlight this kept him
de-powered but eventually he was free
however he ended up flying away leaving
the group behind they still soldiered on
and the war came to a head with them
Stuck in the Middle as the world started
to fall apart the reverse flash arrived
at Tom Barry which is when he revealed
what had really happened though Thorne
had been suspected to be behind it all
it was revealed that Barry had changed
things by going back in time to stop his
mother's murder outrunning a giant bomb
that had been set off in order to end
the war Barry raced away from the
explosion and back into the past to stop
himself from traveling back in time this
worked but it ended up creating another
soft reboot called The New 52 which kept
some elements of the cannon whilst
retconning others that's exactly what
seems to be happening with the DCU as
well which this movie is now acting as a
launch pad for it's crazy to think that
this was originally supposed to release
in 2018 but stuff's been such a mess
that they've now ended up having to use
it as flashpoint's original intention
which was sort of to restart things
anyway the original flashpoint was
adapted into an animated movie which
someone inspires the beginning section
of the film that had a Saturday morning
style team up with all the Justice
League getting back together for one
final showdown though they don't bring
the entire band back together here we do
get some big moments with both gal gadon
Ben Affleck coming back in the film
Aflac lamented recently that he finally
figured out how to play the character
and depending on what tone you like with
DC I think you're either gonna agree or
disagree with him I'll give my feelings
on this first stack later on but I at
least appreciate that they got back a
lot of the older casts to open things up
Batman dons the blue and gray color
scheme for the first time in a film and
he also rides on top of a bat bike that
looks like it was ripped right out of
the pages of White Knight the Flying Fox
appears later on for a split second as
well Jeremy Irons is Alfred mans the
comms and the lasso of Truth also makes
an appearance too now similar to the
comics it's Bruce who barrican fights in
the source material had the pair having
a heart or heart at the end of the work
and in it Barry actually gave Bruce a
letter from Thomas in the alternate
timeline it's one of the best innings to
a comic book ever I wasn't crying there
was dust in the room and allows Bruce to
get some closure on the death of his dad
while there's also play a big role in
the legacy of Barry Allen as his dad was
of course wrongly convicted for the
death of his mother that's something
that affects his Barry too and when
speaking with Bruce they directly
reference the character traveling back
in time during the events of Zack
Snyder's Justice League Bruce warns him
that there could be paradoxes created
but he still goes back which takes him
right into the speed force this makes
him arrive at a sort of speed force
Arena which I think is known as quickly
check the note the Chrono Bowl I think I
didn't jot this down when I was watching
it but I listened out for it later on
and I'm sure they said that Barry here
realizes that he can wind things back by
the second then we see flashes of his
time fighting Henry Cavill in Justice
League and also Jai Courtney in Suicide
Squad we discovered that in the past
Barry's mother forgot to pick up a tin
of tomatoes from the store and that she
sent his dad over to one to get some
whilst he was gone someone broke into
their home and stabbed dare and Barry's
dad arrived to find her dying in the
kitchen the death was pinned on him but
recently Bruce has managed to clean up
some of the CCTV footage to show his dad
was in the store however his cab is
covering his head and thus it can't
exonerate him so Barry has to come up
with other ways to try and fix the past
he goes back in time to the store and
drops the tomatoes in her trolley which
then means his dad doesn't have to go
out and pick them up thus the murder
never happens and then he sets out to go
and return to the present here though as
he's moving back a strange creature pops
out and hits him and this is none other
than the dark flash now if you've ever
seen a CW flash season then chances are
you you know exactly what the twist is
going to be and you can instantly guess
this is an alternate Barry Allen it's
something that's happened throughout the
comics with darker versions of Barry
often grappling with the character and
in the show they played it up with
savitar but here they've kind of
combined elements of him along with a
black flash from the comics now this is
revealed later on in the arena and we
also get some major cameos from across
the DC Universe using archival footage
CGI and actors that were brought back to
shoot little scenes we get a wealth of
people from the past especially when it
comes to Superman this includes George
Reeves who appears in a black and white
World Christopher Reeve back as Superman
teddy Sears is Jay Garrick from the CW
verse Helen Slater's Supergirl Adam West
is Batman and lastly Nick [__]
wow cage who is playing an alternate
version of Superman anyway the Nicholas
Cage one's playing off the fact that he
was originally supposed to play the
character in The doomed film Superman
lives there's an amazing documentary
called The Death of Superman lives which
Chronicles all the things that went on
with the Tim Burton film and ultimately
why it ended up falling apart in the
scene he's fighting a giant spider and
in the documentary they kept talking
about in The Script how producer John
Peters was adamant that they have a
giant spider in the movie this never
happened but Peters later went on to
make Wild Wild West which yep giant
spider at the end now I was a bit
surprised that they didn't include Grant
Gustin at all with them weirdly opting
for Teddy Sears instead I know Ezra
appeared alongside granting crisis but
it would have been nice to have at least
acknowledged them here Teddy is playing
Jay Garrick though like how he did
originally in the show however I think
John Wesley's ship would have made more
sense if you know how that plays out
nikolaj Costa Waldo who played Jaime
Lannister makes an appearance as a guy
who who's about to eat a pizza which
flash grabs so you can fill up on some
calories he does this later on the movie
to a photographer as well and he's
played by none other than director Annie
machete a while back it leaked that
nikolaj was in the movie and many
theories came out that he was actually
the reverse flash that's not the case
though which it would have been good but
he's just there to bite down on a pizza
before it gets taken away now Nicholas
and machiari actually work together on
Mama so I think this Cameo is just him
bringing his friends in now the whole
thing with Christopher even Helen cider
has caused a bit of a kickoff online due
to how bad that the two characters look
Helen's okay to me but in the case of
Reeve I feel a bit funny with them
resurrecting a dead guy to basically use
him for Cameo points in the past moments
like this in Rogue one and so on have
been used at least to have a character
whereas he just pops in and basically
just stands about badly to me you have
to be Flawless when pulling this off and
it looks really bad which massively
diminishes its impact and makes it
almost psychic parody I am still unsure
exactly how I feel about it but my
initial gut reaction was that they
should have just let the guy rest anyway
they're Cameo so you know it's not
really make a break for the movie and
what the film itself is built around is
Barry meeting up with his younger self
in the year 2013. dark flash hits him as
he's traveling home and this knocks him
to the point in the timeline where Man
of Steel was set after giving his powers
to the Past Barry he tries to train him
and wants to track down the Justice
League but they're not actually formed
Tamara Morrison pops up when Barry tries
to ring Arthur and his dad answers to
reveal that he never met Atlanta Wonder
Woman hasn't emerged yet yet we're
forgetting 1984. cyborg still playing
college football but they do know who
Batman is and Barry of course knows his
secret identity this takes them to Wayne
Manor which is where they're shocked to
find the mansion from the Tim Burton
films which in real life's known as
nebworth house lots of cool items here
including the Joker's laughing bag from
the 1989 film and they also have the
Japanese warrior suit that popped up in
that movie movie upon exploring the
kitchen which appeared there too Bruce
leaps out of a cupboard and shows that
he's still got it even though he's now
living life like Howard Hughes Batman
Returns returns and I have to admit I
loved seeing him spewing catchphrases
even if they were a bit on the nose now
they decide to get nuts and want to head
out to get Superman due to zod's attack
on earth now being imminent thinking
that he's in Russia this is where they
find Supergirl instead and if you cast
your mind back to Man of Steel then
there were some Clues towards this
you'll remember early on that clock goes
on at the Kryptonian ship and here he
finds an open pod which many have linked
with her Supergirl in the comics was
sent to Earth before Carl in order to
protect him however things didn't work
out quite as planned due to time in
space Kalel actually landed before her
even though she set off first saving her
is where the movie really ramps up in
terms of action scenes but like Halal
and Flashpoint she doesn't trust humans
she's been completely drained of
everything and crypto get their powers
from the Sun so starving them of it
causes them to become almost skeletal
this is something that we saw when the
nuke went off in the Dark Knight Returns
comic bark and also during Batman v
Superman in a similar scene we discover
that Zod actually intercepted his ship
and that he killed the baby Kalel
believing that the Codex was inside his
blood in this reality though it's in
Super Girls instead which eventually
leads to him attempting to invade Earth
like how it happened in Man of Steel the
group wanted to take the fight to him
but Barry needs his powers then this
leads to them attempting to try and get
them back in one of the movies many back
to the future references he's
electrocuted through a similar sort of
means to how the kite works and the
clock tower in that film he fails to get
his powers though but eventually
Supergirl flies him up into a storm
which is when he finally manages to
regain all his abilities and this takes
us to the big scene in the desert
against your boy Zod Michael Shannon has
been openly talking about the movie and
he recently said that he didn't find his
role here all that fulfilling compared
to what he did in Man of Steel well kind
of wild that he's doing this before the
movie even releases but the man he
clearly doesn't give a [__] either way
though not throwing [__] on the guy but
I can see why he was handled the way he
was as he's not really the main
antagonist here it's in fact Barry who
is a big fortnite battle plays out with
Barry two donning a spray-painted Batman
Returns suit and general swanwick
getting murdered by Zod kinda telling us
out of order as Supergirl leaves them
sees Zod killing swanwick and then flies
back to help Barry get his powers but
this drastically Alters the way that
things played out as soups originally
went up in the ship now they also bring
in the Batman 89 batwing and eventually
this leads to the death of Michael
Keaton's Batman and Sasha Kai's
Supergirl they're unable to defeat sword
which I'll talk about in just a bit but
the deaths actually change a lot of
things going forward now for the next
part of the video I want to talk what
was originally supposed to be the plan
here and what they ended up changing it
to I have done a full breakdown on the
ending scenes if you want to see this
more in depth but I thought I'd just
cover was going on at the time with
Warner Brothers when the movie was
shooting so originally you might
remember that Michael Keaton had been
announced as taking over the role of Ben
Affleck in the DCU he was gonna become a
Nick Fury type figure who would act as a
mentor to all the heroes and basically
be the bridge that brings this all
together Keaton also shot scenes with
Batgirls and this death was going to be
retconned with the original ending now
we know this because scenes of it were
shot publicly and in it Barry was going
to return back to the present and at
this point his dad would be announced as
being freed from prison and
Mercedes-Benz would then pull up which
is when Barry would recognize it as
being Bruce Wayne's and he'd rush over
to it which is when Michael Keaton would
step out sashikai would then drop down
and we'd end with a big WTF moment the
pair would then remain in the universe
going forward but this has been changed
in favor of going with James Gunn's DCU
plants Batman Brave and the bold's gonna
be based on Grant Morrison's run and it
will feature the father and sonju of
Bruce and Damien played by brand new
actors now the way the movie ends might
make that seem confusing because what we
get in appearance by George Clooney
Barry arrives and accidentally slightly
exposes he's Batman but luckily no one
really hears or pays attention to it now
it's kind of a similar scene to what we
were originally gonna get as the Michael
Keaton version wouldn't know who Barry
was but having it here also poses far
more questions like I said I have done a
more in-depth breakdown on this but yeah
a lot of you might be wondering if this
means George is going to be the DCU
Batman going forward and yeah I I have
questioned that myself and this Cameo
actually leaked a while back and people
instantly hit up gun asking if Clooney
was a dcu's Batman he denied it and said
they were going with a new actor and
nurse I think that this is probably just
gonna be a joke for fans to end the
movie on Clooney got a lot of backlash
at the time and Hans joking about how
bad of a Batman he was but fans have
kind of come around on the cam take and
I personally think the movie is
hilarious and I know there will be
people who think he's the worst thing
that's ever happened to comics in
general but you know just lighten up
mate it's just it's really stupid and I
I enjoy it it's a guilty pleasure I'll
say that now I know there will be people
who think that he's going to be Bruce
going forward as well but I I can't see
myself seeing it even though I could be
wrong now we know that Flash 2 isn't on
the horizon for the upcoming slide and
with Annie machietti potentially
directing Brave in the Bold it'll
probably be a while now until he gets
around to even starting work on his
second film for this I imagine they
would have to address it in that which
it's gonna be so far in the future uh
personally I just think they'll not
address it at all and yeah they will
just be left wondering what the hell was
that about now I'm guessing that Clooney
could also potentially show up in
Aquaman 2 or cameo in something down the
line and we know that Ben Affleck was
cut from the film to keep things
streamlined The Flash was originally
meant to release after Aquaman 2 but
they swapped the order which then kind
of forced them to shoot the post credit
scene for this film involving Jason that
has him stumbling around in the street
drunk which is when he lands face first
in a puddle whilst Barry explains you're
the Batman so I'll just a big joke scene
again with Arthur demanding more beers
and it shows that at least some elements
remain for the DCU going forward however
that won't be Keating a Kaye and their
death forces flash to realize that he
can't beat sod and what they can do is
keep traveling back in time over and
over again to attempt to play the battle
out differently and this takes us back
to the Chrono Bowl if you cast your mind
back to Zacks and that is Justice League
then you'll remember that the heroes
originally lost to Steppenwolf but flash
traveling back in time helped them to
win where things differ though is that
zod's attack is a fixed point in this
timeline and no matter how many times
they go back there's no way to save
Supergirl and Batman now thematically
this plays into the movie's true meaning
future Barry is willing to accept
there's no solution Razia there isn't
and they want to hold on to the past
this could definitely be viewed as a
metaphor for the DCU fan base as as
people who want to keep the older actors
Raz guns now bring in the new ones if
you follow the channel for a while then
you know I've always been fond of
Snyder's work and I hate the way that
some stuff like Henry Cavill being
brought back and then dropped was
handled by the company so I think this
can kind of be seen as a metaphor for
that but whether people agree with the
new direction or not remains to be seen
in the case of the film's plot Barry 2
constantly goes back to the battle and
after being heard over and over and over
again by all the Kryptonian weapons this
eventually becomes the Black Metallic
armor that covers his entire skin the
dark flash goes to stab future Barry but
pass Barry jumps in the way and thus him
dying wipes out this dark version this
clears the way for Barry realize what he
has to do when he decides to travel back
in time and rearrange things so they
play out the same way he removes the tin
of tomatoes from his mother's trolley
but he does somewhat say goodbye to her
in this Supermarket scene in the car
makes Barry traveled home to her
directly to tell her the truth Raz here
he pretends to be someone else either
way a big point that they make in the
comics is that though Barry lost his
mother he still got to keep the memories
of growing up with her that doesn't
happen in this film but he does say that
she'll be alive out there so Somewhere
in Time they just won't be able to
perceive it there are theories that time
exists everywhere all at once unless the
past present and future are all
happening right alongside each other
it's just Humanity's view of linearity
that gives it the order but now due to
Barry altering how he perceives things
he knows she's alive at some point so he
says it's goodbyes but we later learned
that he did in fact still shift some
things at the store the tomatoes were
placed on the top shelf so that when his
dad went to get them he looked up and
thus the camera was able to capture him
due to Bruce cleaning up the footage it
can now be entered as new evidence and
it exonerates his dad allowing him to go
free now as Michael Keaton's Bruce
explains in the film Shifting the past
even just a bit can change things from
before the original event was altered
using two strands of spaghettis he
displays this as the timeline and at the
center point where things change the new
one skews off so it changes the past and
future this is how Eric stolts can be in
Back to the Future and originally he
filmed scenes for the movie before he
was replaced by Michael J a fox so this
is why Barry doing the tin thing changes
what Bruce looks like in the past and it
leaves us as a different one to the
Michael Keaton version that ends the
movie with Barry's tooth falling out and
I'll guess we'll see what guns plans are
going forward now answer my thoughts on
the movie I know that there's obviously
a lot of controversy surrounding it due
to a number of different issues Not only
was the movie in development hell for
years and years due to a number of
directors getting fired but he then had
numerous scripts being made and then
alter this stuff with Ezra Miller I've
read a couple of different reviews where
they talked about how you can't say this
is a good film because of what happened
with Miller which I personally think is
wrong when you're reviewing a film I am
a Critic so I am just gonna stick to
criticizing the movie rather than
spending the next 10 minutes talking
about something that doesn't affect the
script performances or the plot of this
film if you want to hear that then
there's tons of videos out there on the
subject but I think if I'm making a
video that's a review of the film then I
should just review the film now I did
try and keep that out of my mind when
watching it and I will also try to go in
with the hype hopefully not affecting
how I saw this playing out Judah Miller
not being able to market the movie
they've had to go above and beyond in
other ways and they pulled out the likes
of Tom Cruise and Stephen King to say
that the film's amazing Gunners said
numerous times this is one of the best
comic book films ever made and while I
think it still has some good moments in
it I wouldn't put it up there as that
and that doesn't mean it's not
serviceable and there's a lot here to
like whatever you think of Miller the
performance here is really well put
together and considering that they're
playing two parts it's an even bigger
achievement you will forget that this is
someone who's probably not reacting to
anything in the scene with them and that
they had to film every scene twice in
order to give the two barriers to scene
together Ezra kills it with both and
it's an incredible feat to pull this off
to the level that they do and they're
also aided by Michael Keaton who it's as
good to see back as I thought it was
gonna be Keaton is one of my favorite
actors and there was some time where he
kind of went off the radar for a while
after playing Batman Sherry did stuff
like white noise which I liked but he
never really hit the highs that he used
to be at until he got the major Revival
with Birdman since then he's done a
number of Great Performances with his
being the case here too I know a lot of
it's just kind of him saying stuff from
the older movies but I think he brings
enough here on top of it to really add
to it the opening is incredible as well
and all this stuff involving the older
cast is absolutely brilliant though
Sasha kayes in it for a very small
amount compared to what I was expecting
she also somewhat steals the scene she's
in and I really hope that they bring her
back for the DCU in the future now where
my problems lie with the movie comes
surprisingly in its First Act I was told
that this was a big and bombastic
Saturday morning cartoon but I didn't
really Vibe with her all that much felt
very Justice League and the whole baby
scene Bruce spouting off about how he
should give his money to the poor and
Barry admitting he's a virgin I was a
bit like hmm I know it's lasso of Truth
stuff but just the tone of it you know I
wasn't expecting that this would be a
celebration of Snyder's work which
obviously has a much darker tone and
they kind of lean more into the camp
sort of town that Joss Whedon went with
when it comes to DC I must admit I
prefer the dark attack on stuff and
that's not just because I'm a snyderbot
but also with stuff like the Batman Dark
Knight trilogy Joker you know that
that's more what I tend to lean towards
I think it just feels a bit off when it
comes to my personal tastes but yeah
like I said I know people enjoyed it so
if you're fine with it then it's not
gonna ruin the movie for you now one
thing that I also found in that opening
was that Barry was annoying as hell and
I thought that when the second one got
introduced that it just went to a
ridiculous level I was sitting there
thinking no way can he be like this the
whole movie and to be fair they didn't
do that and they actually used it really
well in the end and you can actually see
how the characters change and mature
over the film which actually makes those
more annoying scenes work a lot better
although I didn't really gel with that
first act at all I think by the time
they get to Michael Keaton that
everything just falls into place and it
starts to really come together however
where all these scenes are let down is
by the often times of abysmal CGI that
riddles the entire film there's a lot of
CGI characters in this that look fake as
hell and the effects stop this movie
from being as good as it could be it's
weird that Zack Snyder's Justice League
had half the time and budget that this
movie did for effects and that came out
looking way better when this is intended
for a theatrical release I watched
Avatar 2 last week and that's kind of
set the bar now for me as to where I
think CGI should be at for 2023. I think
a lot of this looks really bad and I
kind of wish they'd taken out some of
the money from the marketing budget in
order to pay for the effects to be
polished they've done crazy over the top
marketing for it including program drum
flights at betray the film's logos and
they've had to do this because they
can't really use their star to push it
the budget for the film's rumored to be
around the 300 million Mark and for it
to look like this it is pretty wild it
was also supposed to release in July
2022 originally but it was delayed a
number of times due to the switch-ups at
Warner Brothers so to have it completed
almost a year ago and I know they've
done reshoots but to have it breaking
much all done a year ago and still look
this bad at points is unexcusable to me
No One's Gonna remember the marketing
plan with those flying drones in five
years time but the poor CGI is going to
be something that lasts forever so I
think they should have put more into it
now another issue that the film has is
that it's releasing two weeks after
Spider-Man across the spider verse
there's actually a lot of similarities
with that that I think are gonna make
people put the two up against one
another I am going to spoil some of the
elements from that movie so if you
haven't seen it then skip ahead 30
seconds because I'll just be talking
about how things are the same okay go go
right yeah that's enough time so if
you're watching this bit then you've
seen that movie and in both films we
have a hero who travels across the
Multiverse a parent's life or death
controlling the fate of the entire
universe and an alternate version of
them that ends up appearing there's a
lot beyond that but yeah one film is
about trying to do anything to change
the Canon Razia there is about accepting
it now in my opinion across the spider
verse does this stuff better so the
flash rightly or wrongly gets a bit of a
negative gleam to it due to coming out
so close to it flash also suffers from
the fact that we've had so many
Multiverse movies already which I've
sort of used the same sort of trops
weirdly this was put into production
before all the ones that have come out
before it but it's now releasing after
meaning that they have had time to go
and steal its Thunder you've had so many
movies now that have brought back old
actors dealt with the Multiverse and
even Award winners like everything
everywhere all at once that
unfortunately has taken away from what I
think would have been a groundbreaking
movie had it been drawn before all those
of the films however I still think this
is a great movie and it's helped by
brilliant performances some hilarious
jokes and a lot of moments that
celebrate the history of DC I think this
is a really good film and definitely
worth checking out if you're watching
this review without going to see I don't
know why it would but thanks for
sticking with me now with all that being
said this is the best DC movie since the
Dark Knight I know I say that about
every DC movie but this is a DC movie
that dark tonight The Dark Knight best
movie Dark Knight there's three Dark
Knights in this movie making it the most
Dark Night
so you don't know what happened there
but yeah but that's a joke it was a crap
joke to be fair but I think in the end
that this movie deserves to be seen it's
not one of the best comic book movies
ever made but it's a good time and
that's why I'm giving it an 8 out of 10.
and that's kind of my right out of the
theater reaction and I'm sort of
hovering between a seven and an A but
for how I feel at the moment I think it
would round up to an eight instead of
going down chill I guess yeah still a
shell but my issues with that First Act
I think our soul does the movie goes on
but my score May drop down once I've had
a couple of chances to watch it now I
think that this film is gonna be
absolutely torn apart on Twitter but
overall it's a good Flash Film and a
good adaptation of Flashpoint I know
though that deep down the DC fan base is
gonna go to war over this film for the
next couple of years and people are
about to end friendships over what
happens in this film gonna be non-stop
endless arguments a never-ending War so
hug your family tonight brother because
tomorrow we fight and obviously I'd love
to hear you your thoughts on it what do
you think is going to happen in the
future are you going to be fighting a
civil war all day tomorrow on Twitter
make sure you comment below and let me
know you want to support the channel for
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you you'll get early access
to videos every week we also have a
merch store over at xeroedition.com
which sells lots of nerdy inspired
t-shirts hats and more we just launched
a secret Invasion slash Pulp Fiction
inspired t-shirt so if you want to head
over there and help us out then the
links in the description if you want
something else to watch we've got a big
breakdown of the post credit scene along
with that George Clooney reveal so
definitely head over there right after
this there's still so much to talk about
I will be covering the flash more and
more and huge thank you for sticking
with me until the end I've been Paul
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time and you take as off and enjoy
your weekend peace
foreign